strap on in this episode is an absolute
monster of a ride with a ton more clues
about what's going on and some heart
pounding action if you're new to my from
videos this is not a recap rather a deep
dive into all the Mysteries Clues and
theories the show has to offer I've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering now come with me
the sun's about to set episode 6 once
again introduces us to the ballerina
music box something we saw briefly in
episode 2. Martin told Boyd that he must
quote get out before the Music Stops but
we never find out what exactly happens
should the music stop this time however
the music box is accompanied by a
ballerina which directly ties to the
name of the episode
a French term describing a dance between
two people it can also mean cooperation
between two people which is what is
needed when it comes to transferring
blood Boyd is the only one who can see
the music box and ballerina suggesting
the worm infection that's take taken
over his blood is giving him this
ability remember in one of his Visions
the ballerina even pukes up worms these
worms also have given him visions of
Father catry it'll be interesting then
to see if these Visions will cease now
that he seems to be cured of these worms
I'm curious if the music box in
ballerina serve a different purpose
almost as if trying to tell void
something Boyd sees the music box
outside the cellar the same one where
Victor hid the night of the town's
Massacre and the third time he sees the
ballerina this episode she grabs him and
makes this gesture to her arm almost as
if she's wanting him to recognize the
importance of his blood now speaking of
these worms we get a few more clues as
to what exactly these things are the
worms seem to be a physical
manifestation of a blood infection that
can be passed from person to person
Martin gives it to Boyd and Boyd to
Smiley and it appears that once you pass
it on to someone else you are cured Boyd
theorizes that the worms eat away at you
you using its host as a food source yet
at the same time it keeps the host alive
that's why Martin wanted Boyd to kill
him he had been fed on for years the
worms also seemed to have an adverse
effect on the monsters in episode 2 the
monsters don't seem to notice Boyd when
he's out in the forest although it's not
proven if that was because of his blood
however in this episode Boyd's blood is
transferred into Smiley causing him to
shrivel and turn into one of those
pruned monsters Tabitha and Victor saw
in the caves and before we get more into
Smiley if you like these types of videos
and want to see more consider liking and
subscribing it really helps the channel
out perhaps the biggest WTF moment is
what happens to Smiley after reacting to
Boyd's blood I personally don't think
he's gone he's the most notable monster
of the bunch so if he doesn't shrivel up
and die when daylight comes what could
happen I think it would be really cool
come Sunrise if he turned back to normal
like the person he was before becoming
this monster this could act as a really
cool plot device to answer some
questions about the town's past and
could open up new avenues for figuring
out just how the hell to get out of here
we've also never seen what happens to
one of these monsters should they not
get back to their cave in time that's
another possibility the other mini
Cliffhanger we get this episode is that
Fatima could be pregnant with Ellis's
child to my knowledge there has never
been a baby born in the town so I'm
super curious whether or not this will
provide any new clues in terms of plot I
think having her pregnant would raise
the stakes and also provide cool new
things for the show to explore although
given very little screen time this
episode Jim expands on his theory that
this place is all some kind of
experiment meant to test them stating
that the food shortage is a way to
increase their stress levels we do know
that someone is definitely watching them
as evidenced by the radio call at the
end of season 1. before Boyd reaches the
cellar where he sees the music box he
makes an odd remark that the leaves are
changing colors something that he hasn't
seen he year before Victor also remarked
that the trees were changing before he
showed Jade the abandoned car lot last
episode this suggests that prior to the
last two episodes the town had been
stuck in summer almost Frozen in time
now these comments on the leaves could
indicate something bad is about to
happen or that the writers had to come
up with a way to explain the changing
seasons due to the production shooting
schedule Elgin really stepped up this
episode and put his life on the line to
save Ellis he didn't have to do this but
did anyway we learned this episode that
he can't stand the sight of blood which
is why he leaves when Christy performs
her surgery he's also the only person to
show compassion to Sarah I wonder if his
backstory involves some sort of bloody
event in which Elgin himself would be
seeking forgiveness hence why he
empathizes with Sarah and walks away
from the blood he did mention he was
going to see his grandmother so I wonder
how she plays into this or if that's all
just a lie I absolutely love the writing
in this scene between Ethan and Donna
last episode Ethan told Sarah that he
doesn't fear her stating that when
you're on a quest you take away a scary
thing's Power by facing it but Ethan's
secret is that he's still scared with
Donna telling him fear is special
because without it we wouldn't know how
to be brave we also get a bit more
backstory behind Marielle last episode
we saw her stealing morphine to feed her
drug addiction it looks as though
Christie knew that Muriel was once a
user but when they were together she was
clean it's only when Christy went
missing that Muriel relapsed and was on
that bus to get back to rehab now I turn
it over to you I want to hear all your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember
your blood now [__]